yo i cannot let you get up out of here
uh without giving us some knowledge on
this these giannis stories uh i know
windhorst said it um
a lot of a lot of people been writing
about the mavericks like everybody else
you know wanting to pursue giannis and
tentacomo if he passes up the super max
in milwaukee and decides he wants to
take his talents elsewhere apparently
you know they got uh
they got some front office connection
whether it's donnie nelson or whoever
they feel like they got an inside track
on attracting him to playing alongside
uh luca which is scary but feels a
little
feels a little crowded but whatever yes
yeah yeah redundant there's the word
that's yeah that's what i was trying to
get at um what do you see in giannis
future man first of all is he leaving
and if so is dallas really uh one of the
leading suitors for his services
i don't know if he's leaving i don't
know if dallas is going to be the place
that he would necessarily go
you know playing with porzingis
and and luca it sounds nice but i don't
know i think that might be too much on
the plate the two teams that i heard up
when i was in the
[ __ ] when the buffer was going on the
two teams that i heard were the two
teams at the top of your list miami and
toronto now with the way miami put out
and we know about heat culture and we
know about the way that pat riley likes
to go after the stars and the fact i
love to see that south beach
like you can you can add him to jimmy
butler
and the way that jimmy played and add
another top guy next time and it doesn't
feel crowded it just feels like they got
to figure out who's in charge and we
know who's going to be in charge and in
toronto toronto has the international
flavor with messiah you jerry and their
long-standing relationship so i would
not be surprised if maasai
goes big game hunting again look he took
a chance on getting kawhi leonard and he
gave up the mother rose and to do it do
you think that he would not do anything
less
to try to get antenna cumpo in toronto
take the chance on the relationship and
go from there i think dallas is like
that to me dallas goes after every big
free agent right and they still haven't
gotten one remember they were supposedly
in the lebron sweepstakes in 2010 they
were supposedly in the dwight house
sweepstakes in 2014 and all these other
different things and they never seen the
clippers that guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah him too yeah yeah
all of them and i and i think they have
a good organization a great head coach
but i don't know if giannis would sign
up necessarily to play with that team i
think
that's what it is deandre jordan yeah
neither one of us would like my man from
the clippers either one of us
like uh your boy your boy yeah
yeah
but i i don't i don't think there's any
i don't think they're
ahead of toronto or miami if it comes
down to it
yo dog um
next time you you got that that many hot
takes next time you're going to spit
high five like that let me know and i'll
just take the day off
yeah you could be you could be one
brother all right anytime dawg
you